In the third and final part of our interview with Matthew Brown, the author of the Immaculate
Constellation Report. The submission of this report onto the congressional record and its
announcement caught people by surprise. Its distribution was allegedly very tight and
these unelected members on these congressional staffs that get to set the agenda for our elected
leaders had to scramble and adjust in real time. They panicked. What I have learned is that
we live in a dream, a carefully constructed reality. We make use of a science that is
tightly controlled and suppressed and distorted. Who are they? Why are they here? Why don't they
show us what's going on? I think I have a good degree of confidence
that we're going to be able to do this. I think we're going to be able to do this.
The reason they're here is us. I think life, especially sentient life, is a precious thing.
And I think to some, it might be a resource. I think humanity to some level is a resource
for them. It's been a very painful, costly process to find allies, but I have them.
There's more of us. This doesn't stop. Right. You get to know some of these other
whistleblowers who are still...
Still not public yet.
Correct.
But who are at least close to coming forward.
Yes.
Is there a strength in numbers in that regard?
Yes. And if all of us die or are imprisoned, the seeds have been planted. More will come.
I fly out to California and I meet with Michael Schellenberger.
I told him, hey, I got a story for you. Would you like to chat with me?
Mm-hmm.
You know, I had met him previously, very briefly, totally something unrelated.
Yeah.
And his work on the Twitter files defending, you know, free speech against a very pervasive
and insidious censorship regime that our government, even before the Biden administration
had implemented, inspired me that he would do the right thing.
Logical, great choice. You know, that was my hope is to have a lot of journalists working
on this from different angles who you can trust, who are honest. So that's where your head's at?
Yeah. So we have a good meeting.
Yeah.
I, I, I would prefer to like, maybe cut it down because it's pretty long.
Right.
But you get to look at it and are you interested?
The answer is yes.
We're going to do a story that's in summer of 24, I believe.
Early summer, late spring.
so with that in hand and knowing that i had at least tap tapped uh sask and sissy um thought it
was okay to move forward with that story and then try to talk to house uh with you know the full
details um in the meantime before that story came out you know it takes time to bet things uh he has
to look into me just you know find out who i am look into the details of what i'm alleging you
know i know that george and i know the process well so it takes months you know so i got some
time and in that time um i for the first time get connected with uh david grush i've had a very
enlightening conversation with him and at his suggestion uh he connected me with with you
um and that is how how we came to to meet yeah and i'm looking uh not to report on what you're saying
initially i'm looking to help you achieve the goal that we're all fighting for which is getting the
people asking for it the information that they're going to get from the people that they're going to
get this doesn't have to be public it doesn't have to be a public display this is let's facilitate
these conversations that's where we started i'm not really doing journalism work with you i'm
trying to just help the process go that's how that was my headspace yeah i was asking gresh like i'm
having a real hard time a meeting members themselves and b just even talking to anybody
in house who's the guy to go to and it was you okay so uh that was our the nature of our meeting
george and i have had a great relationship trying to help facilitate information knowledge and
human beings in for this sort of thing so it it makes sense it was a good move we did well with
david grush uh so george and i's our role oftentimes is to connect people we are reporters it is to
break stories tell the news um but really a lot of what i was personally doing was trying to facilitate
help facilitate the process they're asking for um at that time we had had a great hearing uh david
grush uh also quentin fravor who had to beg to testify um it was great it was a success everything
was clean on that one on that hearing this was a new thing a new era it felt different from the
get-go but the idea was we're going to have another set of hearings i'm all for that they tapped me to
try to help connect them with people and george and so we've had many calls through many process
and and now i'm out there to have meetings directly about first-hand people with first-hand
experience who can directly connect with people who can directly connect with people who can directly
testify about this whether they talk publicly or not this is the information you need so i go to
have these established meetings you and i meet i do uh you know physically and we talk about it
and you want to come with me and i can bring you in but i can't let them know because we're still
trying to protect you trying to protect your identity so it was kind of like we'll talk about
it more in depth later but a kind of harrowing experience you were very nervous i mean it was
like you're exposing yourself in the in the you know in those meetings absolutely right and just
by walking into those offices or the buildings those offices are in right right very public very
public so we kind of hid you in the in the camera crews the way i say it and that you were walking
with us but but and getting into the buildings but i asked each member i said okay you wanted direct
people i have one here to speak with you everybody needs to leave the room including the cameras it'll
just be us is that cool and and each one although they gave us wisdom along the way as we did our
progression of getting you right through the meeting and getting you in the right direction
and getting you back in front of people to give them your quick testimony and some documentation
so that's what we went through and we go in and there you are you're sitting in front of
and you know somebody with position i just want to know what did that feel like first
of all that that moment where you got to finally get to them uh i mean in the moment it just was
somber serious um also you know nervous i got a i got like
you know it's five minutes but i only have probably like a minute to speak bro you were
sweating you were stressed i mean it was it was intense so getting yeah getting most important
information across and also establishing my credibility as fast as possible uh and i was
making sure you weren't a plant you know to be honest that was part of the process is
making sure he'd say the same thing to um you know to to congress that to members that he said to me
not that i didn't believe you and i had done the vetting
and i i i was there but i want to hear you say it show it so you're not trying to entrap me i mean
honestly that's part of my thing um man we got through that didn't we it did it worked well
it did so you come out of that thinking okay all right this is good i made contact i mean we'll
see where it goes mold yeah yeah pretty strong yeah i mean at this point in time i'm very
uh actually a skeptical is not the right word i do not believe did not believe that this would work
in congress but i knew that the attempt had to be made we had to try he had to try i knew that i
alone wasn't big enough or important enough to to shift the tides of history there to shift what
apparently the executive branch had decided which was we are going to squash this
and anybody that tries to bring it up we are going to uh
you know silence cutouts uh and disparage they were asking for whistleblowers and there we are
blowing the whistle on this and that's what they were asking for so for me it was a big win
for them to meet you face to face because i knew down the line if this is going to progress look you
would have testified let's get real clear on this they were asking for it
you would have testified you were not asking to testify you're saying here's the little piece that
i have but you you said in that room that you would if if requested i would if asked and i did
not want to do it at the upcoming hearing of course because that was very close and i in no way felt
to do that but you put the ball in their court and you said you would they didn't ask right and
we got to there's a whole thing about that but just you really put it out there i did yeah okay
i think um it'll take quite a change in our present circumstances for anybody to ever testify
under oath on this subject again in a way that would make a difference i think uh they know the
power of in in an open hearing
putin' your hand on the bible and swearin' that you're gonna speak nothing but the truth and
doing so it's symbolic and it's very valuable and that is why i believe that they are desperately
attempting to deny well and that's that's what we saw um you know we don't gotta rehash that
that's what we saw the second hearing absolutely controlled uh representative burchett testified
to it by saying it publicly that the executive branch um did limit what could be said and by
who and george just brought that up a bunch when you know so so
i agree executive branch in the halls of congress determining what the business of congress is and
not even through the courtesy of a phone call to the vice president of the president but through
minions and stooges unelected probably cia yeah well certainly yeah when you when you hear about
the lineup for the hearing that was held you got to be feeling pretty good about it oh yeah there's
got to be a witness he's going to talk about immaculate consolation and not just a witness
on his own next to uh lou elizondo tim gallaudet and this guy i've never heard of before but seems
nice nick gold or michael michael michael great they're thinking all right good all right it's
going to come out we're all punked did you know what exactly what was going to be discussed by
the schellenberger at that point yes i mean i knew it was going to be you know me uh and my words and
my report and because the two of you met with them the night before the hearing well yeah and
i mean i
you
met with michael to give him the story i seem like there's no mystery here why they're bringing
him yeah there was a lot before that too but um i mean i have a two plus month process of
prompting trying to get something on congressional record knowing that what your your testimony was
valuable it wasn't just like spur of the moment there is a process it was three major meetings
that occurred to validate the information that um that you provided to me it's not just like
um getting on something on congressional record is a little bit uh more tricky than than people
think they have to have time with it so i very slowly with your authorization over those months
had in-person meetings not just you being there but then working with them showing them the
information so they had time to vet it they're worried about getting scammed too right so it was
a process this process that for me was very arduous personally there are a lot of phone
conversations that we sat in on with uh
House staff. And it got curiouser and curiouser as the people who were in on these conversations
with us on the other end. National security folks just popping in on a meeting that I'm
supposed to be having with them. They wanted to know what assets George and I have to visually
show them. We were going to provide them. They were saying at one point that we were going to
testify. And I said, cool. And I want to give something substantial to the American public.
This is what I want to give them. Well, at some point, they're trying to get us into a skiff.
And my federal lawyer, our federal lawyer said, do not go in there because they will
immediately classify all that information that allegedly you may have access to. And then
you're never reporting on it. So we went through our own journey. We don't have to get into that
in this discussion, but there was a lot of stuff happening behind the scenes, but hurrah, hooray,
congressional record, your report, which is misrepresented when Nancy Mays talked about
big time, but we're happy. We're happy.
And I was
stoked to have Michael Schellenberger, who at that time, I was like, this is great. He's going to
be a good ally moving forward. And he's the right man for the job.
Yeah. But bottom line, no matter the shenanigans involved and how revealing that second hearing
was about the control mechanisms in place about UAP, I was elated. And I think so were you that
without having to put your face out to the public and endure all of that, like you're doing and
going to experience now.
Your testimony got put on a congressional record. That was a big win.
Yeah. There was a bit of a personal pleasure too. We, I, at the very least, got to see
someone else be scared for once.
Who was scared?
Not the bosses of the people who interfere in Congress, but the minions themselves,
because their bosses didn't tell them what was going to happen.
Can you dive a little deeper into that?
Well, by all appearances, both behind the scenes,
and in front of them, the submission of this report onto the congressional record and its
announcement caught people by surprise. Its distribution was allegedly very tight. And
these unelected members on these congressional staffs that get to set the agenda for our
elected leaders had to scramble and adjust in real time. They panicked.
See, having something on congressional record is different than just putting,
out a news report. News report goes away, one click, done. This is much bigger. And I saw that
too. So I, it was a big move and it was probably, was filled with pleasure to see. It stirred shit
up.
Yes.
You know, you've said it before, and I want to drill this home. At one time, saying these words,
putting these words in text, saying them over the phone, there was repercussion for that.
At one time.
I understand it.
As I understand it as well.
But so.
It gets published. And I was stoked. I remember that day I went on a news show and I was like,
I had nothing. I didn't do it. Somebody put it out. I mean, you let me know that it was going to be
public, but I was like, I was like stoked to hear those words mentioned, but getting it on record,
watching the tables turn was, was filled with pleasure.
Yeah. No long-term outcome, but this is a fight without many wins. So.
Okay.
Take the small personal pleasures.
As this news travels, is there a blowback? Do you suddenly realize, hey,
something might happen to me?
As a result of this getting out there, you're happy that it's finally there on the record,
but then does that change, uh, over the days or weeks afterward?
Not so much. Um, I was not definitely under no illusions at this point. Nothing would
functionally change, but what mattered was, you know, adding new fuel to the fire to look,
what looked like was a dying cause.
Uh, is there a blowback for you personally? Does anybody call you and say,
you shouldn't have done that? Or does somebody figure out who you are?
Is there an attempt to identify who you are?
I'm sure there were attempts and I'm sure some of them were successful, but, uh,
I mean, I've been known to internal security undoubtedly since almost day one.
You know, here's the deal. Um, people misunderstand because it was misrepresented
in Congress. This is not a Pentagon paper, a product. You are the author
of what the world knows as the Immaculate Constellation Report.
Yeah.
This is a report based upon a field report based upon your investigation,
what you've discovered, trying to do the right thing, bringing it to the people that need to
see it because it was so hard, even though they're asking for you to get it to them.
So just to be really clear for the fundamentally for people, Immaculate Constellation Report,
what was submitted into Congress onto congressional record, which we fought together to get that done
is your words. It's not some government Pentagon report. Like it was misrepresented by Nancy Mason.
Converse.
Not at all.
Uh, all my words, um, a hundred percent, uh, authored by me.
One of the striking things for me in kind of talking with you through this process,
supposed to just reading the final report that went on to congressional record. I mean, you
list and label, um, cuboid formation of metallic or these are UFOs, right? So fast mover observed
transiting over satellite or sorry, sensitive facilities, um, intelligence vessels positioned
to collect on reproduction.
Vehicle, uh, equilateral triangle, UAP tails, unwitting vessel. This one struck me
large disc using clouds as concealment. And why that struck me is because George and I have been
exposed to a lot over the years. And I think I know, and other people know what you're referencing
in here. It sounds like you watched a video. You said on us government networks, there exist OPIR
footage. What is it?
Overhead projection.
Persistent infrared. Um, that might be a correction that a satellite may not have been
an OPIR satellite after all, but this one, um, and, and you keep going on a boomerang shape,
jellyfish shaped, uh, you know, tick tack shape. You're not just making these words up. Like you
saw visual evidence of these. Yeah. And, and so didn't have George Knapp and I, we have been
exposed to, um, along the years, a lot of visual evidence, but this one, the, the large disc, um,
in the clouds, just explain to me seeing something like that.
Well, number one, it's
pretty striking cause you're watching it from Sphinx. It's always cool to watch satellite feeds.
Um, and that's just something that general public doesn't get to see. Um, and then two, just the
size of it, it was immediately like, well, what the hell is that? It was in, I assume infrared,
uh, either yeah. Black hot for that one. Uh, so the white clouds around it and yeah, it's, it's
almost playful in its activities or like it was startled. Um, but it's one of those cases where I
look at it and
you know, it looks like a flying saucer, but it might be one of the things that
maybe that was actually one of ours, um, the wrong place at the wrong time.
Uh, what do you mean it looks startled? What does that mean?
You know, it's just looking at an area over the ocean is what it appears.
And this thing just comes trundling along, uh, like underneath the cloud cover comes up.
And then right when it's like almost center frame, it scoots off to the side and like tries to get
out of like, it comes into a certain and going, oops, I'm being somebody spotted me. I exited.
Exactly. That, that it was visibly that's the feeling it had.
That was, that was kind of haunting to me. I checked, we checked, uh, when we were with
some friends recently, um, I never know, we are not qualified to know if some of the things we've
been exposed to are legitimate or not. But when I get confirmations, like you describing this and
other people we've just recently talked to, I know that footage exists. We've been exposed to it. And,
um, I think that that's, uh, a nice piece to the puzzle for the public.
Um, what about jellyfish?
Yeah. So, I mean, I only heard that term, uh, once it was released, uh, similar stuff
I had seen on the inside and it was often labeled like a floating brain
or, uh, an organic or irregular shape. So that's why it's in there.
Um, so yeah, I've seen multiple instances of instances of irregular shaped things that look
thematically similar to the jellyfish. Um, I've never seen that jellyfish video itself.
Um, you know, but seeing those, uh, you know, there's an instance of there, one in South com,
uh, right at our border crossing what appears to be, uh, into United States airspace. Um,
let me get undetected from Mexico. I believe from one way or another, I can't recall the
compass orientation right now, but I would assume into the U S which is why it was interesting.
Uh, yeah. Let me get clear.
in a couple of days well first of all you know people like yourself you get it's happened with
lazar happened with greg like every word you say you know you're worried about if your memory isn't
perfect this way you've done a great job of really curating making sure what you said is accurate
it's okay to make a mistake it's okay to like not remember the exact equipment that did this or that
in your brain just so um so you're saying the word jellyfish you first heard kind of when george and
i released that thing into the public media jellyfish although it was described differently
for different assets you've seen on servers that yeah yeah yeah that term was describing something
i had seen before okay okay is it but we just called the jellyfish because that's what it was
told to us they had two spaghetti monster was our other option it was said jellyfish works but um
that morphology or shape is something that uh consistently you had seen within these uh classified
servers yes in other contexts outside of the middle east okay you ever see any any video
videos where we're engaging with them either we're chasing them our war planes or something
or going after a disc a saucer an orb or something like that so i've seen videos and read reports of
engagements uh but not live like we're not shooting them but engagements where you know
either we are trying to intercept something um read lots of reports on that and from other
countries as well trying to intercept these things um you know each report will have a
It's own shape that they're chasing, but guess what they are.
But then, yeah, when there's an example in there off the East Coast, what would be classed as an engagement where we're up there protecting our airspace and encountering these things and interacting with them in a way that we would consider hostile.
And if it was if it was anything else, you know, if we had a Russian bomber patrol that had a fighter escort and they tried to box our fighters out, force them down from the wash, the jet wash, you know, that would be a hostile engagement.
But for whatever reason, you know, we're not describing it that way internally.
So we're sending a plane up to take a look.
Yeah.
Maybe get a better look or even some imagery, but not to engage, meaning shoot it down, shoot a sidewinder at it or something.
Right.
I would, you know, I'm not going to be able to say that's never happened, but I have I've not seen them engaged.
Yeah.
With weapons.
Well, it recently happened and we became aware of one more details on that, I think we'll report on.
And what happened was the missile, quote, bounced off.
And so they're trying to figure that out.
But, you know, what does that imply?
Like a field around it?
I don't know.
We also released one that was so embarrassing to release.
We had to call it.
It looked like.
Kermit the Frog.
I think we called it Syria Dome UAP.
But the reason we released it because verified we tried to engage it.
We tried to shoot it.
And I believe we hit it, but we don't know the aftermath or what happened to that.
We reported on that is actual information, even though it looks so silly.
We had to report it because UAP.
So from the recent event to that, it brings me back to what you said, George, about the official orders back in Russia back in the day.
Tell me that real quick again.
So the Russian military that from 78 to 88, they had.
Standing order for the any every unit in this vast Soviet military empire, any UFO or ball of light flying saucer, anything weird in the sky, it had to all be investigated.
And the guy who was in charge of that program at the Ministry of Defense said that there had been several dozen instances where they sent planes, warplanes to intercept these UFOs.
And they mostly they couldn't keep up with them.
They just poof, they're gone.
But in three cases, they tried to engage.
And shoot them down.
Three cases where those planes, the Russian warplanes, crashed.
Two of the pilots died.
And after the second pilot died, they issued an order.
Leave them alone.
Because in the words of the commander of the Russian Air Force, they said they have incredible capacities for retaliation.
So why so many shapes?
Why do you think so many shapes?
I used to think fly saucers were disks.
I used to think UFOs were fly saucers.
That's what I used to think.
Now, after knowing this guy for so long, reading all the reports, getting whistleblowers.
Talking with them.
Why so many shapes?
I think part of it's sometimes these might be, you know, made to purpose.
So, you know, if they're only making it for a specific use case scenario, they'll design it to excel on that mission.
I guess we do that.
We do that.
Absolutely.
We have bombers that look a certain way.
And then we have reconnaissance vehicles that look another way.
Star Wars, they have giant cruisers.
And they have the X fighters for different jobs.
Would you be surprised to hear about cases where these things, large objects, come out of the ocean or go back into the ocean?
Does that sound familiar?
I would not be surprised.
I have not seen very large objects go in and out of the water.
But I've definitely seen small to medium-sized UAPs either going into the water and disappearing or going in and out or coming out of the water.
Fact.
And on video and described.
Is it video and described?
Any kind of change of inertia or multiple videos?
Any kind of, we have also been exposed to some.
Let me ask you this.
Any change of, like, any inertial effect, any change of speed or motion?
It's like the water wasn't there.
It's like the gold for anybody who wants to see.
I wonder if it's ever enough.
Like, is video ever enough?
Like, what is enough for people to wrap their heads that there's a real issue here?
I don't know.
I don't think one video is ever going to change.
I want to talk to you about signals, intelligence, signet, right?
That was a big part of your investment.
Can you explain that and why?
Yeah.
So it was one of the sources where, you know, we have a fantastic intelligent posture.
It's not as data heavy.
So there's just, it's just much easier to move around and access and read through quickly.
Now, it's one of the shortest sections in there because in my mind, you know, those are, these are incidental collections, right?
Yeah.
I'm sure we are specifically collecting signals, intelligence on this, but my research was not in those sort of data streams.
That majority is accidental kind of capturing.
Exactly.
From other countries, other militaries, activities related to this and their observations related to this, or sometimes historic things that we acquire that happened to pop up in those in the.
Yeah.
So the reason there's less detail there though, is we're using those every day.
We rely on them a lot and they're very fragile, very sensitive and diplomatically sensitive as well.
The things you're describing that you'd seen that are in this report are mostly things that are there's in the Pacific and the Atlantic.
There's over Africa.
They're foreign things of something coming over the border from Mexico.
What about cases in the U S is, is NORAD?
Is that just a black hole for these?
Kind of images.
It's so something that happens over our country.
You don't even get to see it.
Yeah.
North com is a black hole.
You need, I mean, just legislatively there's, there's legal things keeping us, the military and the IC supposedly from, from looking at the states, that's supposed to be a domestic law enforcement mission in general.
You got to have a very good reason to be looking at, you know, over your neighbor's fence.
Basically, this is a, I think it's, you know, it's functionally a barrier to present prevent.
Yeah.
That votes.
Curious people.
You know, doing things they shouldn't in our home in our homeland, which would actually get them in trouble.
It's one thing if we're doing it, uh.
Some foreign countries, one thing, if we're crossing the line and spying here without a specific mission.
The complaint we hear from UFO world is I don't care about these blurry images.
These things are blurry.
The TIC tack to me, that was a fantastic image.
You know, there.
You're not sending Dave Fravor up with an IMAX camera to make a movie.
These are captured on sensor systems.
The same as like 2019, the USS Omaha, pitch black, 100 miles off the coast of Southern California.
They're picking up an image that they follow for an hour on a thermal camera.
They're blurry, but they're amazing images.
I mean, is there a reason that the public doesn't see crystal clear movie quality images of UFOs?
Yeah, I think, unfortunately, it's a product of our education system, a lack of curiosity in general about the world.
There's a lot of arrogance in our academy, and that arrogance filters down to our citizens.
We know the world. We haven't figured out. There's nothing left to discover here.
And I think in general, there's so much misinformation, stigma, mythology that people grow up with that lead them to just.
Automatically categorize any of this as just, you know, false, fake, not real, misidentified, mundane.
I mean, getting an image on a thermal camera 100 miles out to sea in total blackness is sounds pretty cool to me.
That sounds like an amazing accomplishment.
But is there other additional reasons that have been maybe discussed behind closed doors?
Force fields of some sort around these craft that make things blurry, even for a.
From the camera image, you know, probably a very real explanation for why certain shapes, you know, are harder to observe than others.
I think, you know, whether it's active camouflage and like the skin of the vehicle itself, that definitely seems to be in play or a field like you describe.
I've seen evidence of fields around crafts.
Yeah, some things we've seen have looked so bizarre.
It makes no sense to my brain.
It is possible.
I've heard that from a number of whistleblowers at different levels that what you're seeing could just be a part of a greater structure, you know.
So it could be something like that speculating.
We had this Chinese balloon thing that happened.
Three different objects, UFOs, three UFOs shot down in a couple of week period.
And then we saw people use that, the usual people in the media world who bash this stuff.
We tried to blame it on the UAP task force.
The reason we're not NORAD is not looking for something like this, because the UAP task force confused the whole situation.
It's as if NORAD would only look for things that look like planes, bombers or missiles.
So we didn't look for UFOs.
Is it possible that we didn't look for UFOs because it didn't really want to find them?
Or is it we were looking for UFOs and just the public and most of the government never saw?
Yeah.
We've always been seeing these things with things like radar.
So it's, you know, it's part of standard operating procedures to to deny this and to not acknowledge it.
So we've been seeing it.
We're just pretending not to see it.
Absolutely.
Our public institutions like the FAA or similar in the even local context, it's not allowed to be discussed.
And there might even be technical measures in the technology at this place that just
prevents it from even popping up on a screen.
Right.
You know, like Tic Tac.
So that happened for two or three weeks.
They could get a little glimpse of it on these systems, really sensitive, advanced Navy systems at the time.
And then poof, it fell off.
At the USS Omaha, they had 12 or 14 of these things zipping in.
You'd see them on the radar screen and then poof.
If they didn't want to be seen, we weren't seeing them.
I guess it could be that as part of an explanation.
If they don't want to be detected on radar,
they have ways to avoid radar, whoever they are.
Yeah, that's a dangerous dynamic to have willful ignorance on our side and their capability to at least attempt to evade detection at any time on theirs.
If we are so certain they are friendly, why is this a secret?
I have one more.
Yeah.
Drones.
So 60 Minutes just did a big piece on drones.
The Langley Air Force Base had these things flying over it for 17 nights.
In a row, stayed in New Jersey for weeks at a time.
Sensitive bases, restricted airspace at U.S., U.K. bases in Britain for days and days.
We can't track these things coming in.
We can't track them when they leave.
We can't shoot them down.
We don't know where they're from.
But don't worry.
They're just drones.
They're foreign surveillance drones.
Give me your take on that whole situation.
Well, if you're a member of the public and you are still listening to CNN, MSNBC,
Fox News, or reading the New York Times or the Wall Street Journal, all of that is
controlled.
It's propaganda.
It is shaping your life narrative, intentionally so.
As for the government reactions to that, I was very disappointed to see a continuation
of the dismissal of these events by the Trump administration's press secretary.
I can guess why they decided, despite the campaign.
The campaign promised to immediately address that issue to not have to do with geopolitical
situations we are currently involved in and the fact that we are living through a constitutional
crisis related to this issue.
It just seems to me that it is a worse thing to say these might be foreign surveillance
drones and there's not a damn thing we can do about it.
We can't track them.
We can't see them.
We can't shoot them down than it is to say these are genuine unknowns.
You know, it seems like they're...
They're unknowns, not just something, some drone that the Chinese are floating off of
New Jersey.
There's an infection in our security thinking, which is that, you know, we must...
They're primacists.
They must be on top.
To admit weakness is to admit defeat.
And to say you don't know what something is, a pretty big signal of weakness.
There's not much humility and a lot of arrogance.
It's driving, I think, these responses more so than any strategy.
Yeah, just I want to defend footage real quick.
I got three things.
I want to defend footage.
There's a lack of education about what people are seeing in thermal.
So first of all, these are weapon systems.
These aren't IMAX cameras.
But they're kind of better than an IMAX camera because you can see in the fucking dark.
So I think there's an education process.
We've been trying with our reporting to teach people when you see something in thermal,
what you're seeing is a heat.
And that heat signature represents that shape and, you know, of the heat.
It's just a...
I think it's an education process.
It has to come from curiosity.
But people need to be told what they're seeing.
It's new to a lot of people.
It was new to me when I started seeing military videos for the first time.
So in defense of grainy, bad footage, people just need to understand what they're seeing
to understand the impact if they're curious enough.
Question, like the...
Like any country in this world could disclose at this point.
A major country with technological development could disclose.
We are not alone in the universe.
There are others whose visitors have been here a long time.
Why?
Why has everybody agreed to not say that to the public?
Do you have any philosophies why?
I think in the West, this is the reaction.
That's an important distinction.
I cannot comment so much on why Russia or China have not addressed this in a different way than us.
But I think in the West and the Five Eyes,
the Five Eyes Alliance and its subsidiaries,
there is an understanding at least that this is not talked about at official channels,
especially if you're a small kid on the block.
You don't speak out of turn.
But it also points to, I think, the fact that this doesn't ultimately reside in the government anymore.
This is held.
This is held in an illegal internationalist regime,
some sort of international cabal of sorts,
a mix of corporate, military, political, intelligence, and criminal interests
that have come together and they have subverted us
and have taken this and have made it the source of their wealth and power.
That's what I asked Matt.
Dr. Edgar Mitchell told me in one of the last films before he died,
he used very similar words.
Well, that doesn't make me feel good.
Yeah, well, he was sure of it.
You're a whistleblower, not a source to me and George.
You know, you're a whistleblower.
You know, I want to, we do want to help.
I always hear whistleblowers are scared.
And we know some people, the same people,
but there's a lot that have come to us that you don't know.
Are you scared?
Are you scared now coming forward?
I mean, it comes in waves.
Okay.
So, yes.
But.
I make a conscious effort every day to not let fear rule my life and my deeds.
So, yes, I'm scared.
But this is the right thing.
It's the necessary thing.
And I was raised right.
You think that by talking to us,
it's possible that you might have some protection in that
if somebody cuts your brake lines and you go off a cliff,
at least there's going to be somebody looking into it and raise some hell about it.
You know, if that happens, don't try too hard.
Focus on the mission.
So this is more about people need to know than about your personal well-being.
Any regrets now?
I trusted too much and I did not trust myself enough.
Took some, I paid some prices and I do not doubt that they're the seeds for future
costs I'll have to pay in the future.
Describe for us the personal costs, the reality for you going forward.
Your outlook.
Your outlook for ever working for the government again, for example,
or in it with any kind of a job that requires a security clearance,
personal cut costs to your marriage, your personal life.
Well, with the job, with government, my career is dead.
It has been dead for years now.
I have a file on me.
I will, even if I went back in, even if I chose to never do any of this and just keep working,
I predict that I would have found my career.
Stunted mysteriously as soon as it would have sought to or would have sought to advance into what I thought was a noble mission.
Personally, it's hard to describe.
You know that I've been doing this for about four years now.
Only very recently have I had anyone to talk to about it outside of like, you know,
Hey, can you make this meeting happen?
I've had no allies.
That has changed.
It's been a very painful, costly process to find allies, but I have them.
There's more of us.
This doesn't stop.
Right.
You've got to know some of these other whistleblowers who are still not public yet.
Correct.
But who are at least close to coming forward.
Yes.
Is there a strength in numbers in that regard?
And if all of us,
die are imprisoned,
the seeds have been planted.
More will come.
Well,
those seeds have been planted about deaths to end the whistleblower community that those stories circulate.
I would imagine pretty quickly among you and people,
you know?
Yeah,
but I'm still here.
You think anybody has been killed because they knew too much on this topic?
Yes.
I believe.
And I think,
and I could probably help someone else prove it.
But lethal,
lethal action has been taken against people.
People that tried to get the truth out or maybe we're just a considered a wild guards on not able to be efficiently controlled no longer useful I think once you taste the darkness like using it they don't have to kill you they get this ready in some way oh yeah manufacture something mm-hmm they they asked you to come forward and you even felt that you had a small piece to the puzzle and you weren't even sure if it was worth it or not.
Yeah.
And then you do that and that what you suffer as the consequences against your career there's other things we're not saying that we suspect are related to you coming forward God that's got to hurt man that's got to be painful that asked you to come forward and you tried all the ways to do that we had to go to a little bit extreme measures to get the rest going it's got to be painful.
It is.
I don't think it will stop being although hopefully time is its own self.
I'd like to spend that time with my wife my family not in a cell or in the ground but you know this bigger than me it's bigger than us this is the fate of our people and to me I'm willing to pay that price is it ironic you have to put your face out with us to protect yourself at that at this point that's what we're doing right yeah that's what we're doing this is absolutely what I.
Yeah.
Did not want to do I know I can attest to that this is not this is exactly what you did not want to do correct have you gamed it out in your head what happens next what will likely be assuming we go forward with this interview and make it public and that right now we don't know that that's the case but when it comes out if it comes out what happens to you then what are the risks well gaming it out there's more than me more will come I could say more.
Hopefully this rises to a level of public attention that demands to be addressed in a serious way I can't cause that alone other people will but more need to come and I think at this point I like to say directly to the members of our military and our intelligence community the time is now where you must choose whether you honor your oath or your orders.
If you have courage you know the answer but for the rest of you lead follower get out of the way get out of the way we know people are coming forward and we know we've recorded George and I with other people who will be coming forward you know so you're not alone but you say you could say more just explain that when I wrote this document I've kind of given my state of mind and the measures I took to protect it.
I'm also.
You know familiar with ways that information can be extracted that passwords and encryption don't matter so I didn't write everything down so there are other bullets left to fire if you needed to yeah you know talk about things getting lost in the shelf I highly doubt many members of the public read 11 pages much less the first but at the end there's an interesting area people might notice that it's out of order to.
Things are.
Sequentially out of order is missing sections.
And that one of the last sections says sensitive sources from mouth to ear.
We talked we talked about keeping that in or what to how far to go with what does that mean well exactly what it says those words were only spoken from my mouth to another's ear.
What is it like to have absolute knowledge that.
Not only UFOs are a real that we've been hiding that that our government has controlled that information away from human the base human population.
And that there is another intelligence that is engaging humanity straight up what what does that feel like being one of the people that knows that and doesn't suspect that it's weird going to the supermarket.
Okay.
Even more it's bizarre to work in government and see legions of people who have no clue about about any of this and no clue that they are being deceived.
Why should people believe you I mean I know I know you I know we've been through but that's not public stuff to everybody every step we've taken why should people believe what you're saying.
I was there I saw it spent years researching it.
If all that I'm.
Consulting is passage material then we are engaged in a massive deception against our own military and intelligence community that I was a victim of and on us and it would have been on a scale that probably would have been its own new story absolutely nonsensical madness yeah yeah so as a human being why should people believe you well as a human being I feel like I'm genuine putting myself out there.
Yeah.
Sacrificing my future my past and a lot of what I have now to do this for no gain and you get nothing from us we're just reporting because it's an important story and you're telling it because it's true absolutely it is it is true and I can't think of anything more pressing for our nation to come to terms with than the fact that we have been deceived and our rights taken away to protect the privileges of an elite.
View you're not I'm not going to I am not going to live my life knowing that I could have helped prevent another generation of America and humanity from living in ignorance so let's just separate you know for audience and people kind of meeting for the first time so there's certain stuff you were exposed to an official capacity that you've come to conclusion on and that you know to be correct no to be true then there are extrapolations and.
Philanthropy.
And ideas from other types of sourcing of information and we can talk about that kind of in a separate room and I value your opinion I think people will too because of your exposure to certain things you're saying and not saying okay but if we're talking just about our ideas now you have thoughts about big picture stuff who they are is it more than one day is it us from the future ETS interdimensionals do you think there's anybody.
In government who knows and and if you if they do know is there any reason why this should say stay secret at least some of it should stay secret that the public cannot handle no the only reason for secrecy is fear and greed and that is the paradigm that we must confront and overcome as for the public and what their reaction might be to this information good bad indifference I think we already have our answers.
It's going to be indifference unless the stakes are made clear you're an absolutist you like rip the bandaid off there's no bandaid there's no wound this is not about protecting healing this is about power and control this isn't about trying to save what's good about getting rid of what's evil power and control meaning controlling the technology.
And what it would mean those are just means to controlling humanity everything.
You suspect that there are reverse engineering programs that there have been crashes that there are attempts to replicate that technology you got hints of it and the a rv or rv yeah that we're trying to build what these things can do do you think we've done it that we've accomplished it somebody yeah I think.
I think we've absolutely replicated some of these.
Capabilities in inferior forms.
And oftentimes maybe disaggregated from what was.
At once a unitary system but we're only able to do a small part what that system does.
We've seen people say they think that the tic tac is something we had 21 years ago and I'm wondering well where the hell is it I mean if we have this technology we've done some of it.
To get even inferior versions of it is that something that's going to be incorporated into the US military arsenal or is it something that's outside.
Of it that's controlled by somebody who's not using it for national defense I think the US military might be allowed to use some of this technology in the national defense but I don't think they ultimately have control over it you know this is a kind of arms race it's a technology race whoever gains the ability to effectively weaponize this they win we know that UFOs due to the propulsion systems.
Are a matter of national security and weapons of mass destruction and we we know that we don't think that we met with people that deal with that right do you agree with that do you think that this is we are in a race with China and Russia there's other countries competing to to weaponize this and do you think that's a problem because you've dealt with weapons of mass destruction in your official career.
I think.
Deterrence.
Strategic deterrence.
Has migrated out of.
Sorry has evolved from being relying on nuclear weapons as the pinnacle.
I believe we have and others have developed the means to maybe utilize nuclear reactions to create some very dangerous effects through directed energy.
Your concern is directed energy weapon right.
Among many.
As but when it comes to WMD's and relations to this technology I think we have been successful in both deriving new science that we have then suppressed to preserve a strategic advantage and I think I probably don't want to talk too much more about deterrence.
Somebody was flying these things that crashed somebody built these things that are being reversed.
They're being engineered.
Who's that somebody and why don't one of the come forward.
I mean you you know you may not have seen that in a document or a file or something somewhere but you've thought about it you're smart.
Guy what are your thoughts on the big picture questions.
Who are they why are they here.
Why don't they show us what's going on.
I think I.
Wave good degree of confidence that the reason they're here is us I think life especially.
Scentia.
Life.
It's a precious thing.
And I think to some, it might be a resource.
I think humanity to some level is a resource for them.
Like a commodity?
Possibly a commodity.
Possibly a form of entertainment.
Possibly medical related.
Think they live here?
Yes.
For all intents and purposes?
Always?
I don't know about always, but it certainly appears that they have been here for most of recorded history.
At least some element of this has been here for most of human recorded history.
You think we would see them if they didn't let us see them?
Even with our more advanced sensors, that they pop up, but they can also disappear.
And do they allow us to get these limpses?
Is that a game of some sort, I wonder?
Or an education process?
It's a bizarre one that I could not understand if it is a game.
I think.
They're both just as powerful as we think, but also less.
And I think there is not a single they here.
Multiple?
Multiple.
Certainly multiple factions of the same species, if not multiple species.
And all the complexity that brings, which might be our best hope.
Do they have an agenda?
There's different types.
You know, what are your philosophies on this?
Like, who are the others?
Why are they here?
And you've touched upon it, I know.
We're kind of going.
Yeah.
Back a little bit.
But that is the big question.
And I just wanted to separate so people understand your exposure and your personal conclusions.
So I have been exposed to no direct information on the anatomy, biology, intentions, culture, politics.
Never came across those files?
Never came across those.
I think those are all some of the deepest secrets.
Right.
They would be if this is correct information.
Mm-hmm.
What I have learned is that we live in a dream, a carefully constructed reality.
We make use of a science that is tightly controlled and suppressed and distorted.
I think we are left behind.
Humans.
I think normies, the normal humans, the people have been left behind.
Us.
Mm-hmm.
People need to...
People need to understand that we might have freedom of speech, but that has been subverted.
We do not have freedom of inquiry.
We are blocked from learning what we need to know.
Just in the public world, we are blocked from advancing in science.
We are taught false science intentionally to prevent us from learning more.
We live in the matrix.
It's just much more boring than the movie.
I think about...
Let's try and go back to the movie.
Yeah.
I think that somehow this is important because you know, you're at home in your school introduérium
ெ
We are out in the market.
Of course we're out there.
as you. There is no hope or help for anything like folks like that, is there? I mean, we've
heard promises, we'll help whistleblowers come forward, we'll give them support, there are private
equity funds and organizations that say they're going to help, but we haven't seen shit so far,
have we? And have you? No, I've reached out directly to institutions that claim that they
are here to help UAP whistleblowers specifically, both in the process of coming forward and
any sort of stability afterwards. It's been radio silence at best, at worst. One of those
institutions has stolen my information. There is no organized help for whistleblowers. It is all
controlled. It is all at either the special interest of industry that wants to get in on this
or by the existing powers that be. Intelligence agencies who have infiltrated or created these
things.
Correct.
I have directly experienced that, sadly, over this last year, which is the vacuuming up of
intelligence on people such as yourself, who are trying to do the right thing as whistleblowers,
as well as anything that reporters could possibly obtain and release. And it is a treacherous
moment in our history of this. You did a call to action to people. You told them,
it's time, move forward. I know that you had some encouragement with David Grush. I hope people are
encouraged.
You know, also by you. Look, man, if you were to die tomorrow because of whatever reason, what do
you want people to know right now? Like, what do you want people to know if you're just like fucking
on?
You are not free. And this reality has far more to it than you have been allowed to believe. And God
is real.